this question it's a tough question
that's why they stuck it at the end
of the 1995 hsc paper so if you are
wrestling with it
or if you just feel completely beat down
by it all right don't feel too bad
okay um can i ask you guys what's your
opinion on why and you've had to go at
it now
for a few minutes what is it that makes
this hard
any any takers there are many many valid
answers for this maui give us one
a linear thing or a kind of pie straight
for the juggler okay
plotting a linear thing moe's talking
about this uh
y equals two minus x graph a linear
function
that's a straight line plotting at the
same time as a
trig graph we pretty much never do that
so that's just weird out the gate okay
i'm sure a lot of you were thinking the
same thing is there anything else that
you guys find difficult
about this that was basically it
yeah sure okay uh do you have one more
sean yeah
you know when x equals minus
yeah yeah okay very good so you're
coming on to the second part we will get
there
um and sort of it's intertwined with the
same thing we just mentioned right
what's going on is this what's our scale
what's happening okay
so i want you to remember right normally
you'd have to write this but normally
when we do a tree graph right
we will either do it in degrees or
radians and you guys know that we
ordinarily go to like 360 degrees right
and it
is super important that we write that as
360 degrees
not 360 right
now when we do this in radians we then
say okay we just put that as what's the
equivalent to 360 degrees
two pi right we just say now forget this
we don't need these units we just label
it as two pi and i don't know if you've
ever noticed
the fact we don't put any units on there
we just say it's two pi
right now that is actually something
we're going to use to do this
question right we're going to work out
where we go
domain and range and everything is going
to be
in radians everything okay so let's
let's have a go at this
y equals 4 cos x probably the first
thing a lot of you asked me this and you
could tell me therefore
the first thing you can work out is its
range right it's how high and how low it
goes
what's the highest value that four cos x
gets to
four and therefore from that
you can also get the lowest value which
is negative four right
are you talking about a shift what are
you thinking of so
so in terms of shift for this particular
graph i think we start with our normal
cosine and then there's no shift at all
actually it just is a
stretch out okay um you guys told me
negative four right down the bottom
okay all right so that's good that's
good
say it again i said plus four at the end
of it the whole thing up yeah if i added
four i would i would take that and then
i'd go
zoop up you go which which i'm not doing
this time okay
now we're saying that we're going from
two pi um also we're going from negative
two pi that's another weird thing that
some of you didn't mention but i saw a
lot of you
instinctively draw your axes just like
this because we so frequently draw from
naught to
whatever right but we're not doing that
here i wonder if anyone's already worked
out why that is
now have a think this is the first trap
that a lot of people hit and some of you
didn't even know you hit it okay
ordinarily you would draw your um
horizontal axis and you don't care
for its relationship to the vertical
axis you're like negative one
one and then you just do your 180
degrees 360 degrees or two pi or
whatever it happens to be
but here it really matters where you put
this okay and you'll see why
later on so here's what i'm going to do
i'm going to go to
not negative 2 pi but to work out where
that is i need to get a sense of the
scale
now we've said that this distance here
is 4. do you agree
now we don't have to but it will make it
easier for us if
we make the horizontal scale the same
you catch that whatever distance that is
on your page maybe it's like three
centimeters or something like that right
if you have if you're not like content
with your graph draw a whole new one and
follow with me
that same distance you've measured out
measured out horizontally
i'm going to eyeball that looks like
about there
and that is going to be four okay i'm
keeping my horizontal and my vertical
axis
consistent okay so that's four then i
guess that means
this is about two that's halfway yeah
if that's two then that's four then
that's six
and the reason i'm putting six there is
because six is very close
to two pi what is two pi it's like six
point
two eight or so isn't it pi is three
point one four
if i double pi i should be just a bit
past
six do you agree with that does that
make sense so what i'm gonna do is i'm
going to in a different color actually
just so you can see it
there's three solutions ah now now
you're talking straight okay i'm going
to put two pi there
okay now this is important you can see
it's actually consistent with the scale
that i had for the first graph
and i'm going to do the same on the
other side i should put um
i should put pi on as well so to get
that on there in an accurate way
pi is close to what integer what's the
closest whole number to pi
the closest we're in radians right we're
in radians pi is 3.14 etc so therefore
the closest whole number will be just
three do you agree with that so here's
three there's three right there between
two and four
so pi which is 3.14 is just a bit after
that
okay how are you feeling is that all
right okay
so far so good now
cosine what's it look like can you trace
out the shape
of cosine when you're here yeah okay it
starts high goes down into the value and
then
it goes back up and ends up at the same
spot right so from
four which is our highest spot i've got
again going down to my lowest spot
at pi right so in fact and this is
literally what i do on my page right i
go to pi
and then i draw a dotted line sort of
down
so i know i'm going to hit negative 4
down here does that make sense
and then i do exactly the same thing
over here at 2 pi i'm trying to get some
like landmarks myself to draw my graph
through so i'm going to do the same
thing over here
how's that does that look okay to you
guys you guys can actually see it better
than i can because i'm right next to the
board
sometimes i don't scroll straight i i'm
okay with that are you guys content
okay um i've got
high points and low points right what
other points are important when i'm
graphing
to know like things i've got to label
onto a graph i'm going to need
intercepts right what are the intercepts
of this
minus as well have a think i will i will
do this other side
in a second but i haven't even got this
part the regular part
look if i've got pi and two pi here i'm
gonna go high
down to low i've clearly got to hit
somewhere in the middle right what's
that middle spot
pi on two thank you so this is important
so i'm gradually
wrong graph one color i'm gradually
building this thing so pi on two
if pi is about three point one four pi
on two is like
one point five something okay so
if one's here 1.5 is going to be about
there
there's pi on two okay i'll stick it
over there and then i'm also going to go
to the other side three pi on two do you
agree you could even eyeball this and
say it's just halfway
okay so i'm going to do that here
okay there you go so now we know where
we're going to go
through do your very best maybe doing it
with a pencil first so you get the shape
right and then
go over it and pen why is it important
to go over in pen
we're thinking hsc we're preparing for
this um they're going to scan this
some pencils come up in scans but some
just do not at all because there's a
light and it just reflects off okay
all right let's do our best to thread
the needle so eyelash did you say
if they don't see a graph then there's
nothing that marked does that make sense
they don't see the actual paper they see
a scan yeah
sorry all right it's scan scan
oh that's a scan the scan is a scam sure
you'll be interested to know that in
fact teachers also
teachers also were really unhappy at the
movement because
you can't be together with the other
people marketing you can't discuss and
that's hard
okay so there's one part of the curve
and i'm gonna do the other side as well
how's that what do you think
it's cool okay now um
i will say because of like the shape of
your hand i'm right-handed
okay if you're left-handed it'll be
opposite but some curves are just easier
to do in one
direction right so i i start from over
here and then i go from the top and
do that and then i gotta take that same
thing
and i'm gonna copy it over does that
make sense so you guys are familiar with
that already let's do this a bit more
quickly
okay hands up if your graph
for cosine looks roughly like that you
okay with that thumbs up fantastic all
right
that part shouldn't have been too hard
okay uh let's label it by the way this
is y equals four
four cos x
okay um why do they ask us to draw it
all the way to the negative side why do
they do that
because they're just cruel have a thing
about the question why else might be
useful
why have they asked the domain to go
over to the left there's actually a
reason in the question
[Music]
yeah okay so this negative two pi sent
us over to the left
look at the other graph we're putting on
here right this is exactly what moe was
talking about
at the beginning right this linear graph
we also have to account for now you'll
see
why this is the point in which i say
here's why putting them on the same
scale is going to be so useful to us
um y equals two minus x that's what
we're about to draw
what can you tell me about this straight
line it's minus two
it's got a minus what does that mean
minus one
like that we go this way okay so instead
of being an increasing function
got to use precise language here right
it's a decreasing function negative
gradient okay
that's the negative what does this tell
us the two the two means
this is the y-intercept right so this is
now we're talking about a shift okay
so here is where four is are you with me
so therefore two has to be about there
halfway do you agree
you see that now a lot of people on this
scale have got it completely in the
wrong spot and that was one of the major
issues
with this question okay now there's two
i know i'm gonna go down at a gradient
of negative one and thankfully i've
already put positive two on my
horizontal axis so i can just join the
dots okay my
my points were wrong but i've still got
three solutions okay
so you can go ahead and you can put your
lines on there
but so if you do a table of values right
yeah my table of values was minus two to
three right minus two to three sure so
minus two if you sum it in you get two
minus minus two which is four
so minus two minus four yeah that's why
i'm up there
see that in fact because my scale is
pretty good
right here's two here's negative two and
you can see i almost
completely line up right which i can do
because my scale
is accurate does that make sense gotta
be really careful with the details